ONE OF THE TRUE
WILD MEN OF ROCK.
['80s metal]
♪
SICK STICK SPIT DECREAUX.
- CRACK ATTACK IS BACK, JACK.
- ♪ L.A. DELI
- [laughs]
- YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHO I AM.
- NO IDEA, FRIEND.
- IT'S NASH RICKEY.
♪ L.A. DELI
- WHOA.
I GUESS YOU ARE NASH RICKEY.
[laughs]
- SO SPIT, YOU SELLING STUFFED
ANIMALS AT THE BEACH NOW?
- NO, I'M HANGING OUT
AT THE BEACH
WITH SOME
OF MY BEST FRIENDS.
PURPLE WHALE,
LITTLE DINOSAUR,
LAWRENCE OF A-BABY-A.
- LOOK, SPIT,
I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME.
WE'RE GETTING
A ROCK N' REUNION GOING.
I'M GETTIN' ALL OF SLOPPYSECONDZ
BACK TOGETHER.
I NEED YOU IN.
- OH, I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
THAT SHIP HAS SAILED.
- I'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET
IN TOUCH WITH YOU.
DIDN'T YOU GET MY LETTER?
- NO, I DON'T HAVE AN ADDRESS.
DID YOU EMAIL IT?
- NO, I DON'T USE EMAIL.
SPAM FILTERS,
INVALID 404 ERRORS,
NO CONFIRMATION THAT SOMEBODY'S
RECEIVED YOUR NOTE.
I LIKE THE PERSONAL TOUCH
OF A HANDWRITTEN LETTER.
THE FONT IS YOUR OWN.
NOTHING CAN BEAT A STAMP
AND A LETTER.
- THE UNITED STATES POSTAL
SERVICE IS OBSOLETE,
NASH RICKEY,
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
- YOU'RE SPEAKING NONSENSE,
SPIT.
- THAT'S POSSIBLE.
I FRIED MY BRAIN
ON CRACK COCAINE.
- THOSE DAYS ARE BEHIND US.
SO I GOT TO KNOW, SPIT DECREAUX,
ARE YOU IN?
I'LL TAKE THAT AS A YES.
- HA.
- SPIT WAS IN,
AND I WAS TWO FOR TWO.
NEXT STOP, SAN DIEGO.